E
VORS METICULOUSLY AND
PERSUASIVELY
THANK YO.
THEY WANT YOU TO GET US TO
HAVING LESS.
THE LEFTANTS YOU TO FEEL LESS
SAFE WHILE DOINGO.
WHAT DO I MN?
WE GOT THE NEW BODY CAM FOOTAGE
OF REVEALING THE YOU'VE L THE
COPS TO BE INCOMPETENT COWARDS
HOUSE JUDICIARY DEMOCRATS A
BEGINNING A MARKUPN A NEW
ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN TO FURTHER
ERODE OUR COND AMENDMENTRIGHTS.
RANKING MEMBER OF JUDICIARY
CONGRESSMA JIM JORDAN.
CONGRESSN, I FEEL LIKE
REPUBLANS AREIND OF AFRAID
OF THEUN IUE SOMETIMES
BECAUSE TY FEEL LE THERE
WILL BE ANOTHERASS SHOOTING
AND THEY'LL BE ON THE SPOT.
T THIS IS PERMISSIONS WHAT
THEY A DOING GIVIN EVERYTHING
THAT WE ARE SEEING IN THE BLIC
RIGH NOW.
>> NO KIDDING
A GREAT MONOGUE.
LESS MONEY IN THE WALLET, LESS
GAS IN THE CAR, NO LESS FREEDOM.
TH ARE COMING DECTLY AFTER
E SECOND AMENDMENT LIBERTIESIN .
SECOND AMENDMENT IS A CLEAR AS
IT GUIDES A SHALL NOT INFRINGE
ON YOUR RIGHTS TO BRRMS.
ITAN'T GET ANY PLAINER THAN
THAT BUT THAT'S WHAT THEYE
GOING AFTER.
ARMS, NOT MUSTS, SHALL NOT
INFRINGE AND IT DS NOT SAY
SHALL NOTNFRINGE UNLESS IS
AN ASSAULT WEAPON OR WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS WAN TO GO AFTER THAT
PARTICULAR WEEK.
I'M GOING TO LEAN IN AND FIGHT
AGAINST TS AND I KNO YOU A
AND SO MANY AMERICANSNOW HOW
ONG THIS IS.
>> I WANT TO SHO OUR VWERS
TONIGHT HOW CNN COVERS THE NEWS
OUT THE INDIANA HERO.
WATCH.
>> THE POLICE SD THE GUNMAN
HAD A HIGH CAPACITY MAGAZINE.
MORE PEOPL COULD HE BEEN
KILLED.
>> ARE W SUPPOSED TO RELY ON A
ARMED2-YEAR-OLD?
>> SHOUL'T HAVE TO.
>> Lau: CONGRESSMAN, EISON
SEEM A LITTLE UPSETHAT'S HOW
IT ALL WENT DOWN.
>> AEW WEEKS AGO WHEN THEY
WERE PASSING THE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL RED FLAG WALLWE
PROCESS RIGHTS, T GOOD GUYS
WITH GUNS DON'T RESC PEOPLE
LIKE TS GUY IN INDIANA DID.
IT JUST HAPPENHIS WEEKE.
THIS ATTACK ON FRIDAY, SPEING
OF FST IT WAS THE COVID LOCK
WN AND YOU SAID THE MONOLOGUEANN
VERNMENT BOARD.
WE HAVE THE JUSTICE DEPARTMT
THAT STILL GREETING MOMS ANDAD
SHOWG UP A SCHL BOARD
MEETINGS SHOWING THE BIAS
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS.
THIS IS PART OF THE PATTERN O
ATTACKS ON FUNDAMENTAL LIBERES
THAT W ENJOY UNDER OUR
COTITUTION HERE IN AMERICA
TH'S WHY I THINK S MANY
PEOPLE ARE SO FIRED UP.
GOING TO PUSH BAC ON WHAT THE
MOCRATS ARE DOING.
>> Laura: FOOD, FUEL, PERSONA
SAFETY,PEECH.
CONG FOR ALL OF IT.
BUT THE VOTERHAVE A CHANCE TO
TURN